-Your next comic is a regular
here at the Cellar.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Rachel Feinstein.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's good to be here.
You guys are nice.
Usually I'm uncomfortable with
warmth.
I can't handle intimacy.
Like, I have to make a joke
immediately after sex.
My husband will get annoyed
because I'm obsessed with those
old movies from the 1950s.
So the moment sex is done,
I like to be like,
"Well, I don't understand
what that all had to do
with helping the children."
[ Laughter ]
"Why, golly, you said if we did
all of those humiliatin' things
that it would help
the war effort.
I suppose that was a lie, too."
[ Laughter ]
"Come to think of it, Wally,
I didn't need to bring my friend
Connie over either, did I?"
[ Laughter ]
"She was piping mad in church
the next day about what we did."
[ Laughter ]
We just got married
a couple months ago.
He's a fireman, and --
[ Audience cheers ]
I mean, I think he's a fireman.
He could just be a stripper
with a fireman costume.
[ Laughter ]
I haven't checked
his uniform for Velcro.
I'm not sure.
[ Laughter ]
We were set up.
How insulting
is this description
he was given about me?
His buddy called him up
and he goes,
"How would you like to meet
a semi-famous Jewish jokester?"
Have you heard a more vile
collection of words?
You hear that as a man
and you're like,
"You know what? I'm gonna
stay in on a Friday night.
I think I'd rather do that."
That sounds like a character
from "Fiddler on the Roof."
Like, "I'm selling riddles
over here!"
It's like a town jester.
"You want your riddle? Ah!"
That was disgusting
and I apologize.
[ Laughter ]
And then he goes, "Wait, her
name is Rachel Feinstein."
I don't have a sexy name.
My name's not doing me
any favors.
That's a name you hear
and you're like,
"You know what? I'm gonna need
to see some pictures."
[ Laughter ]
They make you do the dumbest
things when you get married.
Like, they make you
go to meetings
with these women
with terrible voices.
We met with this woman
and she goes,
"So before the ceremony, what
we're gonna ask you to do --"
Like, if that's your voice,
I pre-hate you.
That's an unacceptable voice.
[ Laughter ]
She goes, "We're gonna do what's
called a 'first look' picture.
It's such a beautiful moment
where we take our groom
and we place him in front of
his bride and blindfold him."
I'm like,
"You're not David Copperfield.
Get over yourself."
[ Laughter ]
"This is happening in a banquet
hall in Staten Island."
[ Laughter ]
She's like, "And then we
whip off his blindfold
for such a magical moment."
I told him I was like,
"When they take off
your blindfold,
you should just be like this."
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Oh, God, is that
a semi-famous Jewish jokester?"
[ Laughter ]
"Show me another option."
I knew he was gonna propose,
but I didn't know when.
So I was in this wild state
of waiting.
I was, like, looking for a ring
in my salad.
[ Laughter ]
I was just reading planes
that went by.
I'm like, "Does that say
'Will you marry?'"
My friends are like,
"No, bitch, it says 'Delta.'
That's a commercial flight."
[ Laughter ]
I just needed, like, a real lady
in my family to take over.
Just somebody that had
strong opinions about flowers.
And my mom is just
too jazzy and liberal.
Like, I call up my mom
and I'd be like,
"What do you do for
table settings?"
And she'd just be like,
"Celebrate diversity"
and hang up the phone.
[ Laughter ]
Like, a few days
before the wedding,
she just called me up and she's
like, "Strong women rock."
I'm like,
"That's too broad right now.
It's not really helpful."
[ Laughter ]
She's like, "Well, I know
I'll be cutting a rug
on the dance floor
for all of those women
kicking butt in Congress."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm always on board
with AOC and the gang."
I'm like, "You won't be invited
to the rest of the evening."
[ Laughter ]
My mom is a social worker
and she works in Southeast D.C.
And her staff has been taking
her to a lot of rap battles.
They think it's hilarious.
And now it's a problem
for our family
because my mom has a lot of
opinions about the rappers.
She's getting very cocky.
She'll be like, "I didn't like
the rapper that won the battle.
I didn't think he was
really from the streets."
I'm like, "You cannot sniff out
the street on someone."
[ Laughter ]
"You teach low-impact aerobics.
How dare you?"
[ Laughter ]
My mom thinks
she's Kendrick Lamar.
It's a crisis in our family.
And she goes, "I do know street.
And I'll have you know, I'm also
a very soulful dancer."
I'm like,
"That's not something for you
to declare about yourself.
That's not for you to decide."
[ Laughter ]
And her dancing is one of
the most confusing things
I've really ever seen.
She sort of dances
like she's stirring herself.
It's just this kind of
problematic frontal stirring.
And there are a lot of
sideways accusatory glances.
[ Laughter ]
I did that at a show
in front of her once,
and she was with a bunch of
her friends,
and she goes, "Ever since you
put that in your program,
now they just follow me
down the hallway at work
and they just do this thing."
[ Laughter ]
She goes, "Take that one
out of your talent show."
That's what she calls my
stand-up -- my talent show.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you guys so much!
Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]